finishing salmon make sure the scales
are removed super sharp knife let the
knife do the work
first off knife look at the gills lift
up the gills slice fill the bone half
way through and come down through out
turn the salmon around tilt it once you
tilt it okay you'll help knife to cut
through the salmon use your hand use the
tip of the knife hear that noise that's
the ribcage come down all the way
through clean the knife every time
lift up the salmon slice through keep
the knife nice and flat but it's not
flat
you know cut a huge hole in that salmon
now check what you're doing place the
salmon back down let the knife come down
flip through clean knife every time it
will sharpen hold the head nice and firm
knife down in and through you very
careful here not to go too deep I'm
using the tip of the knife and literally
just coming in now cross that bone see
follow that bone down but the knife gets
dirty pull it out clean it come back up
hold the salmon nice and firm now
let the knife do the work okay through
and off now from there slice that off
take that off lay that back down come
through there I want to see a nice clean
carcass like that I don't see any salmon
left on there trim round the salmon and
this is where you take these first fine
bones out don't go too deep keeping that
belly on there so that flavor is again
clean board clean knife you've got clean
slices use a sharp knife come through
slice down through the dorsal fin and
remove that off this is a bit of bone
left on there come back up in
and off remove the fin very carefully
every time you do this you're taking off
minimal cuts of salmon obvious reasons
turn that over and then think about the
portions one two three four five so we
trim the tail there one two three four
and this bit here just tidy that up a
little bit
five-second side clean the board down
same procedure again big knife round fin
come off nowhere near as many bones this
time round turn it round
look at the cut mirror what you've just
done there and there we have two four
six eight ten portions of salmon fileted
lines with precision and finesse ten
portions out of your salmon understood